本日は遠くたーーーー始めた皆さんレーザーポインターというものをご存じだろうか
何使われているかと言うと
すんませんちょっと分かりますってレーザーポインターなんですけども私今回4回最強
のレーザーポインが経ってしまいました
こちらがあるんですけどレーザーポインター猫のレザーの入れ物はやばいこれしろ泥は
たくて行ってもの私でも分かりますでは早速開けてみましょう
レーザーポインターどういうイメージがあるかなんですよね僕は小さめでもう
ジャスイメージがあるんですけども私が今回買った最強のレーザーポインター
ライトサーバはこれはライトサーブ見た目はめちゃくちゃかっこいいですよねなんか
じゃ武器って完全しますそれがレーザーポインター世界最強のレーザーポインタと言わ
れておりますお値段なんと
図1前
ちょっとが異様なんですけど恋愛強いかといいますと瞬間にマッツイというかできる神
燃やす
ちょっと強すぎないそれでも最後にはしっかり2020ね最強出力て3つはプレっても
頭がついておりますがすごいなぁ本当にというわけでこのレーザーポインターを今回
使ってみたいと思ったっかー
レーザーポインターって結構危険なで実は私ドクターはじめ
科学者に見えたと思ったんですけども実はただの素人でありまして
彼が来ちゃうんですけどね専門的な戻って
たときやはり安全に考慮した状態でやらなければいけないということで今回ですね安全
に考慮して行うために遍満母の方に見ていただいております
課税お願いしますはいよろしくお願いしまーすお願いしまーたし無理でしたお願いです
あのふわふわ以来ですねそうですね全然レーザーポインターなんですけども
やはり危険ですか危険ですね一番危険なのはみー
に入った時これます目の奥が
いた発明する可能性あるみたいなそうですね船で既に先例お話いただいてヴェーザーが
入らないようにするためのお客さんが住みたい専用ネットを買わせていただいていたん
ですよちらでございますこれ爪だけ中止しなきゃいけないということですね
[音楽]
ちょこれで目の安全を配慮して行なっていきたいと思いますですね今日はですねこの
レーザーポインターを使っていろんなものを燃やしたりなんかレーザー当ててみたいと
思います早速末入れてみたいと思います
はい電源が入りましたねは早速持たせていただきます
いきますああ
[音楽]
メガネの効果ですねあそうなんだ皆さんにはどういったかわかりませんけど
縦先生と僕からは10%増2点があるぐらいの見え方しかしてません
結構者すごいですねそのぐらいしないとやっぱにわたってます
a と同じところに当て続けない方がいいですよ
これます
[音楽]
1回キャラていただきますちょっと暗いところでとは良いですねこれ多分はいと良い
部屋を暗くしました
それでレーザーポインターの軌道が結構見えやすくなるはずですが続いてみます
今
映像
2型のてぃ無理とかがないとビームが見えないんですけどこれめちゃ苦節いるので何も
しなくてもゲームが見える外し方でてねはい画面がマッサージャーヤバそうだとして
これがフルパワーです
うわもう
ワーコレ直視できなこれすごいです
家で使っちゃダメです誰ですけど
あ
[音楽]
の
アイスという先生なんていう場所に移動しましたはいコーデでは水のズームモバ釣り外
はすすぐとなりもう外でやってるとかを飲んではないところでちょっとを燃やしてみ
たいと思いますこれで電気的せた方がいい
飯村みたいになったらでいました
いきたいですうっ血を出してみますね
[音楽]
6は会おうあでもいいか水皿ですけどっ
以前のジャックのほうでしょ
そうだ活用します
キャーなんでこれを買って早速ぐもーやしちゃいましょう
まず風船やってみたいと思います
空いてるの数千の配置が出来ました早速レーザーポインターを当ててみたいと思います
が年生
行かせていただきます
はい q から言います
わっはっは先生
今のでたってようは弱ですよそうですよ
いきます
はいっ
ああを強い
出力上げますはいうん
あれっゲイ行おう
ん
一箇所を数滴なきゃいけないん
色によって反応が違うんですよねそうですか
私は売った
後ろは強いんですか
ほんとな濃い色ははれそうな気がします隣の絶対言われますねこれ
ああああやい一つ
決してっていう
線成功
そしてこうやって引越あの青い光なので
この青い光を吸収する色から
言われるんなるほどなるほど走る人ってほとんどの光を反射しちゃう
なかなか破れそうなんだよ僕と声を張っちゃいますいきます
curva はーよっ
おおおおおおおおおお
ポッをん
[音楽]
はい時で次はですね新車生が思えるみたいな事を言うと思う
クロエもが僕に左を吸収するなるほどなるほど
ちょっと買ったばっかりで心が痛むんですけど黒い t シャツにレザーでてみたいと
思いますであります
やっぱん
ふわぁ
人でてみます
やはりで設定伸びてますっ
service bitter だと思てますねます
を表しかん
そう接雪
政府はもういりません
これはすごいですね超強力ですねそれ戦でこれ
黒いのは覚えるっていうのは買ったんですけどね木の板とかと思って
上げますねなんか8かけるんじゃないですか
何本だぞ私ですねそれぞれ a 書いてありました
はいみなさんも多分エイサーの光の強さは勝ったと思うんで
明るいまま行ってみようと思います骨導のうちの班がわかりセンター方面へは行かせて
いただきます
俺
パンッうわぁ
[音楽]
エッセジャもうすぐ春だよ凄い
できました馬ですねあっありがとうございなんか結構すぐきましたね
そうですね一般にダメージ加工レザーで行ったりとか
aa を作っていたっまぢっかー
そういうのに使うこともあってもっと強いのになったらもう買ってきた
金属切れますね怖いです先生
香りをやってみたいですああいう相撲なる3
氷セッティング完了です痩せて早速予備校に当ててみたいと思います
いきます
ウェアー
どうしてるのか購入は透明なので光を吸収しないんで
えっうわぁめっちゃくちゃなんか溶接みたいなのできると思った
というわけでかけてんで相当できましたもう完全に人とかも来ない安全な場所で行って
おります見えてます
全く見えないです何も見えてないんだよめざパだけで
目指す見ていきましょう注意がいくあって絶対に空気に
ハイムいけないことなるほどその書買ってたらも危ないですよね
今のところなさをですねつけてみてもいいですからね
夜行でわっ
いきますね緊張せねぇ
いきます
入っをあへぇ上これ
レーザーポインター問いかけんじゃないかもこれ反訴しないからつけてなくていって
くれそうですねあの
各3種
いやの中だとを観察
ああああああ
ねこれもビームサービスで方も増え5詐欺でしょこれ
3000てこのな付属品があったんですけど
これなんですか
分校レンズ方面白いことにいうちょっとつけてみます
つきました下に向かってがっ
音は撃ちます
[音楽]
はいえっそれで凄いです魔方陣ぐ
展開されてほしいですねそしてあの
このさっき回るんですよえっすごいすごいすごいクロスはこれ愛知曲他にも種類がある
のでこういうのはたくさんあるんですねちょっと新しいつきました
つけますはい
[音楽]
すごいすごい待って待って待ってエッセ j
ふーん
ぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーすごいってこえーいえーい
うさこレジュメんですよ地面図面で起きてますこれ
運行レンズっていうのは一つの光をたくさんに分けちゃうんですよな
分ける光で分校ですね
を稼い次ですいきます
何ありがにいうなかっ
[音楽]
すごいいきますはい大
おすごいすぐすぐすぐすごい
こんな綺麗なことある
俺は女が落ちますあぁん
pou dou dou
ん
[音楽]